live this is 8 news now weekend edition
who will be crowned Top Dog it's been a
weekend full of competition for police
canines across our neighboring states
for the 31st Annual lvmpd K-9 trials
competition Victoria Saha shows us what
it takes for our canine officers to be
on patrol
those Four Paws to the test Kristen
Halverson and his Belgian Malinois
Dexter as the canines go through various
courses
Lieutenant Jeff Clark with Metro's K-9
section says the canine trials are a way
for the public to appreciate how
dedicated the dogs are to their jobs the
mere presence of a canine Officer and
his partner on scene de-escalates a
situation we'll give a give a bad guy an
opportunity to give up because they
don't want any part of our dog currently
Metro has 17 Patrol dogs and about a
dozen other dogs to detect narcotics
explosives and human remains the canine
section is absolutely instrumental in
the mission that we have to make Las
Vegas the safest community in America
but then also to de-escalate volatile
situations throughout the weekend the
canines are tested on a variety of their
skills Sunday was the agility
performance K9 Arco here is a veteran
performer good boy its canine art goes
third year performing at the canine
trials he probably isn't as nervous as I
am he doesn't care it's just it's just
fun for him like playing a game but
funny
Squad
Street
marriage they're not afraid to do the
job but then also they can be sweet at
the right time and while we were there
we realized there were some family
friendly competition between Metro
Sergeant Eric Hutchinson and his brother
officer David Hutchinson with the Fresno
Police Department from Thanksgiving
football to uh trying to show up older
brothers show them that little brothers
even better which means if their
brothers had some competition then so do
the cousins Jack and Arco
[Applause]
that was Victoria Saha reporting at the
K-9 trials are part of a fundraising
effort to cover the cost of vet bills
for canines when they retire